gazey park appeared abandoned on monday
after the remains of protesters tents
were cleared away
only a police presence served as a
reminder of the violent scenes of the
past few weeks
demonstrators say the removal of their
camp doesn't change anything despite the
police they vow their protests will
continue
casey park has become an image a symbol
for the people the public
it represents freedom it represents
resistance
so shutting this place down doesn't mean
anything the people are resisting
the government is maintaining a hard
line against demonstrators on sunday
prime minister recep tayyip erdogan
again called the protesters terrorists
on monday his deputy said the army would
be called in if necessary
but hundreds have continued to take to
the streets here in istanbul and
elsewhere hundreds of union members
started the week by walking off the job
in solidarity with the protesters of
gezi park
the government warned anyone taking part
in rallies would face the consequences
we won't allow these kinds of activities
and behaviors because they're not
covered by the law
our police will carry out their duties
the government's hard line has met with
international criticism german
chancellor angela merkel has voiced
unease about ankara's crackdown
my view is that what's happening in
turkey right now doesn't fit our ideas
about freedom of protest
about freedom of expression
the makeshift camps may have been
removed from taksim square and gezi park
but in turkey simmering tensions still
remain
you